how's it going bros my name is baby pack
welcome to Just Cause 3 it's one of
those games where they just didn't give
a single [ __ ] about realism they were
just like hey let's just make a game
that's actually fun if it makes sense
you're fired
alright I just assumed that's how the
meetings way and it looks like they kept
the same idea going Jesus Christ I'm on
a [ __ ] plane what the [ __ ] man I need
to get a better computer why why do i
why do I have this [ __ ] ok I'm shooting
that I don't I hope I'm not killing
innocents oh [ __ ] that's awesome good
thing I have infinite rocket launchers
boom [ __ ] don't worry about it Jerry
you're fine ah that works how did that
not kill me there we go oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Plan B everyone well it looks like a
we're gonna die
I'll never mind
infinite parachutes that's right
[ __ ] awesome now here's the best
part of the game the [ __ ] grappling
hook and parachute the most awesome most
genius gameplay ever honestly when in
doubt just crap LaHood and parachute and
Rico his hand catch my pokeballs
it looks chubbier there's no way they
survived that are you kidding me
barrio unrealistic a cutscene events
what that [ __ ] okay so now we're driving
a car awesome
barrio let's not make any mistake on how
we're driving now we're talking baby
kill the innocents later [ __ ] there
you go [ __ ] Jesus Christ how's it going
guys how's it going in there awesome
Yuri loose our tire protect the chop yep
can do that too good thing I'm an
excellent driver
good thing I'm an excellent driver
not a problem all right gonna edit that
out
all right here we go
attempt number cheerless uh and it's a
little Oh God
are you [ __ ] kidding me ah [ __ ] this
[ __ ] sin more sensitive than woof
okay we're fine
it's my stop oh here we go awesome
yes
did someone say something and yep
no problem here oh here we go okay ha ha
ha ha ha ha and then we hold shift to
reach oh oh oh but I believe we do this
oh there Benny ah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
yeah yeah oh yeah what the [ __ ] is she
why I need to go and I get this illusion
with the [ __ ] it's so good it's so good
this gang aah aah aah
sweet bliss [ __ ] yes
space to jump up cliff are you mad main
wings wingsuit whoa whoa aah aah look
[ __ ] that was close
that was [ __ ] close it said let's
let's blow the [ __ ] out of this bridge
man there we go ah good night sweet
prince
oh look at this Stephon make you want to
go to space pitch for man yeah what are
you doing stuck look at him
I have no reason to live ha ha ha it's
like a skipping room okay you're right
we owe infinity and beyond here
adventure I want to try something here
you're right now you will go to space
whee she's fine ah I love this bus wait
get out of the car hey you know what
stay in the car stay in the car see you
back here yep
have fun fun [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] crabs you're right we
oh [ __ ] pops oh that bounce forgot to
wear a helmet really dangerous to not
wear a helmet you know all right
hi Sorry mate this is mine now you can
just ha ha ha ha now let's get some hose
well this is awkward
alright I'm supposed to protect this car
look at it she looks to give oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] she's fine
all right first I could play this all
day this is so much fun I let me know if
you wanted me to do more I would love to
do it leave it like if that's the case
and I'll see you for us in the next
video left-handed here stay awesome
breasts